so pretty incredible scene from
Westminster this week as MPs return to
work and try to vote in a socially
distance way members of parliament had
to queue right through the pass of
Westminster forming effectively a conga
which even stretched outside luckily it
wasn't raining at the time this all came
after the government decided it wouldn't
renew the measures that had allowed MPs
to vote and participate in debates from
home and it's left some in Pease those
were shielding and unable to take part
pretty angry one of those MPs is
Labour's de North Hajj who joins us now
and you've said that the change of rules
has left you disenfranchised what do you
mean a bit of a victory Sophie
in that the government decided at the
end of last week that those of us who
can't go in by reason of the age or
because we've got underlying conditions
or because members are family have got
under iron conditions or because they're
women who are pregnant or because
they've got children at home who aren't
at school all sorts of reasons we can
vote by proxy but I have to say I think
watching last week it was a Gilbert and
Sullivan farce
rather than serious Westminster
processes that were taking place and
what's happening this week which has
makes me so angry I'm now allowed to
vote but I can't take part in debates
around legislation so tomorrow there is
a debate on virtual access and I would
like to virtually take part in that
debate I've been told I can't do that so
I am being disenfranchised and
discriminated against on a debate that
is discussing my disenfranchisement and
my discrimination it's just a nonsense
and the government I guess would argue
that at a time when they're asking
people to start to go back to work and
he's need to set an example and there
are certain things that MPs do that are
very difficult to do properly remotely I
mean doesn't equal a point listen the
two three things I want to get back as
quickly as possible but I want to get
back when it's safe and also we've all
been working really hard we've just
found new ways of working as indeed you
have so it's very interesting how I work
virtually have virtual servant surgeries
virtual coffee options vert
I do feel I've been representing my
constituents well the third thing is is
it hard to do well the voting is dead
easy the voting is totally
straightforward and I have to say to you
much more efficient to do it virtually
than having that ridiculous snake going
through right through Westminster Hall
and out into the square outside
Parliament an only actual debate it's
clunky it's a little clunky but we are
getting better and anybody who watched
the liaison committee where the Prime
Minister was held to account by the
chairs of the Select Committee will say
actually it worked rather well so we've
got a lot to learn we can't get better
but just because it's a bit clunky is
that a good enough reason for excluding
so many MPs like myself who want to tape
up let me take an instance Sophie I've
made Tax Justice one of the causes that
I pursue in Parliament we have a list
published at the end of last week of 16
billion pounds that was awarded to over
50 large corporations in loans by the
government taxpayers money among that
this for people like Tottenham Hotspur
where you've got a billionaire owner who
lives in a in a tax haven and companies
one common base chemical company BASF
got over a billion plants I want to hold
the government to account about that I
know about that I've made it my
speciality and yet I'm being prevented
to doing so by rules that have been
brought in not to make Parliament more
accountable and better but actually I
think political not public good reasons
interesting you say that it's a
political decision what exactly do you
mean by that why would you think that
there is this resistance well if you
look at PM cues as you know you
obviously have and so have I over the
last few weeks and you've seen Boris
Johnson against Kirstin Boris Johnson's
always looking over his shoulder he
can't operate without a crowd behind him
braying to support him
whereas kjerstan has been absolutely
excellent at in a very detailed way
challenging the government and actually
making some gains for example
on the issue of health workers paying
that extra bit of the surcharge because
they were also here on immigrant visas
so that we got rid of that that was
through the accountability I think this
is about getting the crowds behind Boris
Appian cues rather than good governance
and ironically Sophie on even that point
the speaker's been absolutely clear he's
not going to make the chamber unsafe and
therefore only fifty people are allowed
in the chamber at one time can I make
one more important point in peas aren't
employees with we're there because were
elected were we employees what the
government is actually doing is probably
breaking three bits of legislation that
they themselves cast so it's the health
and safety legislation which is not
about just about conditions in the
chamber but how you get up to work it's
the equality legislation failing to make
the reasonable adjustments so that
everybody can take part whatever their
condition and it's human rights
legislation isn't it outrageous that a
government that introduces legislation
through the house then takes it upon
itself to ignore or find a loophole so
that it acts against the legislation and
certainly against the spirit of the
legislation
okay Dame Margaret Hodge I Clues my
strong feelings on this issue thank you
very much for being on the program today
thank you